- I feel like we should shoot
a whole album right now,
(hip-hop music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
- [Man] How you doing?
- Good bro.
Trying to make some money.
What up my guy?
- Pretty good.
- How are you?
- Dez, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Gary.
- For sure.
- What's up fellas?
- What's up bro, how you doing?
- Gary.
- Chase, good to meet you.
- Chase, nice to meet you my man.
- I'm Nice.
- Nice, real pleasure.
- How are you?
Love those.
What's up, what's up?
Appreciate it everybody's constructing.
- How you doing bruh?
- What's up my guy?
I don't wanna bother
you, do your thing man.
- Nah, already man, pleasure to meet you.
- I see you doing your thing,
real pleasure to meet you too, man.
- What's up man?
Gary.
- How you doing?
- Real pleasure.
Nice to meet you, how are you?
- Good.
- Yeah man, go do your thing.
We have so much, so much
brand stuff to talk about,
And Superbowl?
There's so much money for all of you
to be ignoring Superbowl.
- Just on Airbnb.
- You just move out, for like four--
You should book a hotel now,
and Airbnb your shit out
and make like five G's.
Superbowl is going to be
the stupidest thing ever.
- For real, definitely.
- Everybody's coming.
- That's why I had to
get a rental, I was like
bro I gotta get something for Superbowl.
You know what I'm saying?
And just for the future.
- 100 percent.
- I'm thinking about 10 years in here but,
Superbowl is just like, one
of those places out here.
But Superbowl, Superbowl
is gonna be retarded.
- Superbowl is gonna be crazy.
This is a nice fucking space.
- I don't want the neighbors to be--
- Just cramping your shit.
- Yeah, you know what I'm saying?
- Of course I know what you mean.
- In five years I wanna knock this down.
I wanna do the same thing I
see visually in this space
but I wanna separate it, so
like, the A room right here,
the B room right here, the club out here.
You know what I'm saying,
the multimedia right here.
some art gallery right here.
- It's nice out here man.
- And then it's like, just a parking lot,
you know what I'm saying, in the middle.
Almost like the Sony lot,
like a baby Sony lot.
Then I can go back and I could put like
two film studios back there,
you know what I'm saying?
- How old are you?
- 29.
- My man.
- For real, man I'm just trying to--
- I know exactly what you're trying to do.
I've been watching.
- I could lose diamonds,
I could lose money.
I could lose diamonds,
I could lose clothes,
I could wreck a car.
- Not this though.
- I can't lose land, I can't wreck land,
you know what I'm saying?
- Smart man.
- For real, you know what I'm saying?
- People got 87 pairs of
off whites but no property.
- Exactly.
- You know what I'm saying,
I'ma run into my man Virgil.
Hopefully he bless me with a pair.
Hopefully I'll see a pair in
the store and I'll be like
damn them shits is hard.
Cop 'em, you know what I'm saying?
Other than that I'm trying to like, man,
forward push, cause even like
coming up in the culture,
just around all the young
cats that's just creating.
I was a young cat making
beats, or what not
I knew different young cats
that were photographers,
artists, whatever but we
ain't ever had our space.
And we ain't ever had like
a, oh yeah this is our boy.
- Plus this market, it wasn't mature yet.
Like what Atlanta is now
compared to 10 years ago?
- Yeah and what it's gonna be.
- Are you kidding?
This is the epicenter of the game.
- Exactly.
- This is, the leverage you guys have?
You at 29, already here?
- [Man] Crazy.
- You don't get it.
It's why I took advantage of the Internet.
Because when the Facebook and Instagram,
when all that shit happened,
I was already grown.
- Yeah.
- I was 32, 33, I already
had the experience.
I saw that show.
Something's gonna happen
whether it's with artists,
it could be some new music
genre, it could be something
and you're gonna be like, wait a minute
this is the same shit I
saw when we were coming up.
And Spotify or when we
took over or Gambino,
whatever it may be, so what
happens when you're good
and you get older, what
experience does is you're like,
oh I've seen this movie before,
so I'm gonna run this blueprint.
It was just, nobody could be themselves.
Now, everybody can be themselves.
Actually, that's why I love Atlanta.
Atlanta's got like 63
different things going on.
There's a big difference
between Childish Gambino,
and Lil' Baby and Russ and like
there's a million things going on here.
- Yeah for real.
- Like in itself,
forget about the culture
of the game itself,
within just Atlanta.
I grew up in the wine business.
That's how great wine areas are,
there's like a lot of
different flavors in like,
one little area, that's
what's going on with Atlanta.
There's like all sorts of shit going on.
Migos and Future, these
are different sounds.
But yeah, man, honestly,
now that we're connected,
DM me your number right now on Instagram.
Oh, let me, it's so funny.
I'm just so used to that.
- Well, you too on the gram,
(laughter)
- It's true, it's true.
You're like standing right here,
you're like standing right here.
I'm like DM me your number.
- For real.
- I just put the sheet rock on.
- It was all open?
- No, no, no, it was brick.
- Oh brick.
- It was like brick before.
- Uh-huh
Uh-huh, I see it.
Your what board?
- Look board.
People been in the studio?
- Oh yeah, you know
I've got so much music.
- I know, I know.
Unlimited right?
For the rest of your life, yeah.
You putting that up?
- Huh?
- You gonna put that up somewhere?
- It was up there.
- What up man?
- I appreciate that my guy.
("Liq & Licks" by Grip)
- Hit me up anytime.
- Real nice meeting you man, for real.
Keep doing your thing man.
- Hey, Alex, nice to meet you.
- Alex, Gary.
Nice to meet you man.
- Kendall.
- Kendall what's up man?
- A big inspiration, man.
- Thank you brother, I appreciate that.
- Cory.
- Cory, nice to meet you man.
- You good?
- Good.
- Real pleasure.
What's up man? How are you?
- I love your work man.
- Thank you my guy.
What up my dude?
Real pleasure.
- My guy!
My guy!
Yo, say what's up to my college buddy Rob.
- What up Rob, how you doing?
- Party in the A bro.
- I'm happy to be here, man.
- What's up Gary!
- What up Baby?
How are you Baby, how are you?
- I'm great, it's good to see you.
- Good to see you!
(Hip-hop music)
- I just love seeing all
these artists together.
- Yeah it's dope.
(hip-hop music)
- This is real fresh.
I can fuck with anything
that says 24/7 365.
Anything.
- What's good my man?
- What's up my man?
Thanks for coming, for real.
- Yeah thanks for having us.
- I feel like we should shoot
a whole album right now.
Fucking nice, man.
I want to get all the artists
together and take a photo.
I want to take a photo
with all the artists.
My guy, how are you?
- Big fan, man!
- Thank you my guy.
- I got here at five, man!
- Anything I can do, man you
know how I show love to you.
- I'ma hit you when I'm
back out in New York.
- Please, please, we'll break some bread.
- I'll get ya tomorrow.
- Alright, yo.
- Alright my dude.
- Look at that, look at that.
- Bro it's an honor, bro.
- That's gonna be
something we look back at.
That is something we're gonna be looking--
- You gotta start a
Gary Vee Freshman class.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
That's basically what I'm doing.
("Liq & Licks" by Grip)